I team listen up
[Music]
Dominic Toretto just went rogue you're
gonna turn your back on family I know it
looks bad don't give up on him so easy
you've only got one chance to make this
family whole again
don't do this done we're ready one thing
I can guarantee no one's ready for this
she's the very definition of a tech
terrorism there's thousands of cars in
the city and now they're all mine
now I know what it feels like to be
every cop ever chasing us
[Music]
Oh
Londyn Abu Dhabi Cuba
our paths of cross before dawn you just
didn't know it I think I need to remind
you why you chose to be here I got no
choice
if you're gonna catch Dom you gonna need
a little help if you want to tell me why
you just put me in a room with this tea
and crumpets eatin criminal you don't
think that tight t-shirts cutting off
the circulation he'll Brian you should
get bigger slice you guys are gonna work
together love to I've been waiting for
this we got a tank
[Music]
you just don't give up either you
thought this was gonna be a street fight
take the wheel what
this is crazy alright you get style
points for that one I don't know why
you're doing this but I know one thing
you love me
[Music]
you
[Music]
these guys are taking this person you
were only supposed to create a diversion
Roman that was complete destruction what
you want for me I'm Roman Pearce man
it's what I do
phase two phase two what's phase two
pounds away you know what I like about
you dawn you're a genuine outlaw but
you're assembling the hell of a job
brother when we get back to the base
beers on me he's about to go up against
the only thing they can't handle you did
you ever think you'd betray your family
the way you did today
Dominic Toretto just turned on us oh
well well you look at that I don't know
why he's doing this
well that wasn't done she's the very
definition of AI tech terrorism and now
she's working with your guy I think I
found my team this should be interesting
[Music]
where I got
this is impossible
which is why they're gonna need a little
help I will beat you like a Cherokee
drum longer than I expected if you're
gonna catch dawn you guys are gonna work
together surprise I just fell in love
I've been waiting for this we got a tank
let's roll
I don't know if the old DOM is in there
I don't give a damn I'm taking you down
so right oh let's play
planning shooting at me I don't know
maybe because you're in an orange
Lamborghini
[Music]
we are about to go on
[Music]
see we're gonna need a bigger truck
[Music]
dumb you're gonna turn your back on
family
you
[Music]
you